REASON.
DAN O'ROURKE REFED HERE LAST
NIGHT.
YOU DON'T SEEECIZIKAS.
MARTIN DRIVING WIDE.
DOBSON TO THE MIDDLE OF THE ICE.
BEAUVILLIER OVER NELSON.
HE SCORES!
RETRIEVAL.
THEY GET ON IT AND THEY HAVE GO
RAISE AN EYEBROW.
IN THAT SPECIFIC INSTANCE THAT G
THAT IHERE!
REBOUND!
HE SCORES!
JOSH BAILEY FOLLOWS UP HIS OWN S
ANDERS LEAD, SHOULDER TO THE
RIGHT BEFORE SO HE KNOWS HE TWO.
SHORT PASS FORIS IS A SHOT COMI.
PAD SAVE MADE BY WITH A LOOK AN
NO!
IT WOULDN'T GO!
ANDERS LEE FOR SCHEIFELE.
TOP DOWN IN FRONT AND THEY  TO
BOX OUT IN FROIER SAVE A CHANCE
FOROFF.
THE BLUE JERSEYS EXPECT THE PUCK
TO
ONE.
PATH YOU.
SAVE MADE REBOUND SCORE!ED TO S
SEASON AND GETS ONE LAST NIGHT
THE ISLANDERS IN BARZAL AND
CHARA AND EXACT SAME LINEUP F F
[ NO AUDIO ]
NOBODY ELSE COMING.
EVERYBODY ELSE FOR A CHANGE.
HE STILL FINDS PARISE.
BACKHAND COVERARDS.
HELLEBUYCK COULDN'T PLAY IT.
PALMIERI LEFT TO BE
PLAYED.  HIS
STICK.
DUBOIS WITH SCHEIFELE TO HIS  O.
KYLE CLUTTERBUCK TAK FACE-OFF AK
GOOD RECOGNITION THAT HEE